it is National Margarita day this day
makes me so excited because Margaritas
are my jam how to make the perfect
margarita we've got to Amethyst joining
us and Heidi joining us both from who
songs Mexican Cantina we know you guys
are home of the original Margarita like
you created the margarita yes we did um
Amethyst in 1941 we can tell the story
yeah I'd love to hear the story while
you make us make us a drink and show us
what we need to do cool so first things
first we're going to put some salts on
our glass here very classic so way back
when in 1941 we invented the margarita
named after the German ambassador's
daughter at the time to Margarita
heinkel oh yep she um helped us invent
the margarita with the help of Don
corlos which was the bartender at the
moment and he put together all of these
wonderful things like our lime juice our
Triple Sec and our agave nectar and our
takea so that's what this is lime juice
tequila triple SEC okay agave nectar
give it some sweetness no sweet and sour
no sweet and sour dogs yeah fresh
ingredients yeah no mixes that will that
is the key to a good margarita I'm
telling that's why I think why I love
Hussein so much because you can just
taste the difference when it's that
pre-mix like it it gives me heartburn
yes yes no there's no pre-mixing here
everything here is fresh
um we originated the margarita we are
the home of the original Margarita so
it's margarita day where should you be
at Busan right okay now two locations
the one in Boca Park which is uh got a
patio although it's not patio weather
today you do that later on when it's
warm what kind of specials do you have
going so we're doing some Taco specials
today as well as we're having the
Mariachis from five to seven I love the
Mariachi and then they'll be at this
trip from eight to ten
um it's buy one get one free margaritas
today what yeah so I'm only buying one
of these and it's going to come with one
of those
yes I love this amethyst that is great
so so the key here is all the fresh
ingredients all of the fresh ingredients
okay absolutely got that fresh squeezed
lime in there too that makes a whole
difference
and then I know we mentioned strip but
we should tell people since I'm Mandalay
Bay it's inside the shops at Mandalay
place got it which is in Mandalay Bay
between Luxor and Mandalay Bay there's
that Corridor right there perfect okay
Heidi amethyst Margarita National
Margarita day and I'm going to send it
back to Sherry Sherry I know you love
your margaritas too you and me are on
the same page here yes ma'am